bio tout le monde sait squeeze vous avez
vu jésus correctement un ace que génial
ce qui se passe absolument rien du coup
et bienvenue dans ma grotte un même si
là vous voyez juste un gros con sur deux
sièges tous les jours je reçois des
messages mais demandant qu'est ce que
c'est mon logiciel de montage logiciel
de capture vidéo mon matos comme mon pc
mon clavier que c'était aujourd'hui je
me suis dit et si je répondais à toutes
ces questions mais d'abord on va
commencer par mes périphériques à c'est
un peu flou de dire ça comme ça
pervers donc ma souris c'est une raideur
imperatore que j'ai depuis maintenant
deux ans et demi à peu près elle tient
le choc et tient le coup 1 et par contre
au niveau saleté elle tient un peu moins
le coup mon cas c'est un réseau à lectra
donc il est pas blond il a pas de gros
seins mais bon il faut quand même bien
son travail jusqu'à ce que la mapad
micro et mon autre casse un réseau
recrutait usb et celui là l art micro
enfin il avait un micro la force de
trois rangées sur les jeux et de le
balancer un peu partout en fin de vidéo
il se trouve que le micro a
littéralement explosé
voilà paix à son âme un mais je m'en
bats les steaks vu qu'il ya celui là bon
clavier ça restera nantes 6 voilà donc
il a rien de spécial c'est un clavier
pas mécaniques avec donc des touches
rétro éclairées comme 99% avec la vie
actuellement fait bien sûr ta foi un
effet son taf comme un clavier et mon
tapis de souris c'est un rêveur je sais
plus du tout la référence à temps c'est
marqué dessus
c'est un réseau goliathus voilà j'ai
pris le plus grand tapis de souris
possible ce que j'aime bien avoir
beaucoup d espace voilà pour être franc
avec vous j'ai eu la chance en octobre
dernier de passer par tenait à 13h alors
je touche pas d'argent contrairement à
ce que beaucoup de gens pensent mais par
contre si les besoins d'un clavier d'une
souris d'un tapis souris et ben réserves
en eau voir ce qui est plutôt cool art
étant donné comment je me maltraites
notamment mon casque à la fin de chaque
vidéo ensuite pour me filmer j'utilise
sont plutôt j'utilisais un canot de 600
décès un réflexe mais pas une caméra
sans appareil photo mais qui fument très
très bien il ya plein de revient du
tueur quitter sa et récemment j'ai
acheté une vraie caméra un une canon hf
g30 la mémoire de la référence ou pas
ensuite au niveau de mon micro
j'utilisais jusqu'à il ya quelques mois
un blue yeti stmicro qui est assez
imposant et en fait vu que je mets mon
siège à sebha le micro me gâcher un peu
la vue au niveau de mon écran fin je
voyais pas trop le bas de mon écran ce
qui fait que j'ai changé
nous sommes le sparc et j'ai acheté une
perche base qui fait que du coup le
micro arrive directement sur ma bouche
je me cache absolument pas une partie de
l'écran le problème c'est que la perche
passe en fait elle prend vachement de
place sur le bureau du coup il ya un
pied qu'à moitié dans le vide et
plusieurs fois mon micro s'est pété la
gueule voilà je peux le dire un jeu là
vous
au quai maintenant passons aux choses
sérieuses bon pc 1 qui en fait qu'à sa
tête entre les blue screen et les bugs
je déteste les pc après il est
vrai que si j'ai pas de pc je peux pas
faire de vidéos
j'adore les pc je me souviens pas par
coeur de toutes les références mais je
pense que l'essentiel c'est de vous dire
la carte graphique cgt 780 té i - d'un
fokker bois donnant les noms des cartes
graphiques on dire des trucs qui vient
du futur quoi la nouvelle carte
graphique gtx titan black edition saphir
de la mort qu'on fait c'est juste une
quelqu'un fait quoi on pourrait dire
j'étais ex numéro 70 et puis on
comprendrait très bien ans est donc
nécessaire c'est un i7 4770 cas cjga
mémoire vive donc deux barrettes de 8
gigas et ensuite au niveau des
références du boîtier et de la ligne je
ne saurais pas vous renseigner m'essayer
de tout est dans la description voilà un
jeu bras sur des airs ce truc ensuite
j'ai deux écrans dont un que j'en
achetais très récemment les deux cd via
ma parce que je trouve ces écrans qui
ont des belles couleurs et aussi parce
que j'ai jamais testé notre marque en
écran pc
les références des deux écrans selon la
description parce que souvent les
références d'écran cgb 5 des aides qu
détroit 8 2 zqsd de 8,6 au niveau de
l'éclairage utilise une lampe de bureau
voilà comme celle ci est donc
sérieusement j'utilise deux sauf boxe
avec l'air pas mal j'ai acheté récemment
j'en suis plutôt satisfait de la jab
sonde avoir dit la phrase que tout le
monde dit quand tu achètes un truc quoi
sabolien voit s'allonger acheter de la
brioche 1 j'en suis plutôt satisfait
était pas mal hein vie ma chaise
peut-être je me souviens pas du tout de
ces références voilà un d'autres
missions voilà ça c'est de truc que je
n'ai pas fait depuis 2004 afin voilà
c'est tout pour mon bureau il pour les
références de mon matos ensuite c'est un
deuxième petit coin gaming ici un pour
jouer poser dans un canapé sur une
console avec des chips et de bière
oui on aime ça bouge avec mal en quoi
elle est en manque d'affection elle joue
avec eux byron me regarde jouer en fait
ben oui je sais c'est dur mais bon t'as
pas le bras donc donc matin juste des
fesses encore donc j'ai un mode télé
dans lequel j'ai mis ma ps4 mecs doivent
soit démarre wiiu et j'ai aussi mis
dessus quelques objets de trucs
collector un dance est plus tard des
lampes figurines qui comme sur mon
bureau puisqu'elle est trop grosse foule
à quelques pas voilà le truc fait ma
taille à wingles comme trop une petite
astuce j'ai retiré ce soldat voilà comme
ça ça fait de violer une de taille
normale
1 allez dégage gros tas de merde bon
j'ai quand même quelques autres objets
tirés du jeu vidéo va d'ailleurs que
vous avez déjà pu voir dans mes vidéos
un pack collector toi t'es nul là c'est
mieux et puis voilà un ça à peu près
tout pour ce petit coin jeux consoles
qu'est ce que j'utilise pour faire un
montage et pour capturer le gameplay ma
voix à eybens gros tabanou
alors certes je fais mes montages sur ce
n'est les gastros certains doivent rire
devant votre écran notamment ceux qui
montrent leur vidéo sur adobe premiere
pro et vous avez raison de rire face à
riom non plus sérieusement à deux
premières pro carrément mieux que tony
vegas pro fin il est beaucoup plus
stable du moins mais depuis trois ans
utilise son nez vegas pro et je pense
que je du rima pour probablement jamais
le temps de tout réapprendre sera de
premiere pro et j'enregistre joël sont à
voir avec le logiciel action 2010
il fait les deux à la fois donc c'est
plutôt cool je vous le conseille pas ce
qui marche très bien il est assez simple
à paramétrer et puis honnêtement j'ai
jamais eu de gros problèmes avec et
j'espère que ça n'arrivera pas je touche
du bois non se paye tout du bois je
touche du gros ménage
comment ça se passe sur fait enlever
d'autres comment ça se passe je veux
savoir 10 mois alors dans mon cas je
commence à tourner à 13h et joue environ
une heure au jeu voilà jusqu'à 14h
ensuite à 14 heures je commence le
montage et je fais des montages jusqu'à
environ 18 heures quelque chose comme ça
et puis ensuite je mets la vidéo en
ligne vers 18h30 ou 19h00 tard 90 fois
sur 91 la vidéo sort plus verte y de
leur trempe mais voilà ça c'était mal
parti
voilà je pense qu'on a fait à peu près
le tour de ma grotte je trouvais ça
intéressant de vous montrer un peu de
tout ça voyons c'est des gens qui en ont
absolument rien à merci à vous de
regarder mes vidéos vraiment pas ce que
vous faites vivre quelque chose
d'incroyable moi j'adore partager tout
ça avec vous et puis vous voulez jamais
dit mais en fait quand je fais une vidéo
sur un jeu pour moi je fais pas une
vidéo seul à parler seul dans ma chambre
comme un court mais j'ai l'impression
que la personne qui regarde la vidéo est
avec moi et qu'en fait je rigole avec
elle et je délire avec elle bon
effectivement la personne avec qui je
délire ne peux pas me parler hein donc
c'est un peu une sorte de schizophrénie
mais bon bref voilà je trouve ça
important de remercier les personnes qui
nous suivent
bien évidemment je peux pas plaire à
tout le monde 1 il ya des gens qui
m'aiment pas avoir qui nous détestent on
dirait que j'aurais fait un mal fou
en bref vous prenez pas la tête à
essayer de convaincre telle ou telle
personne que ce que je fais c'est bien
ou que c'est mal chacun ses goûts chacun
une telle ou telle personne et puis
voilà ça sert à rien puisque je vois
qu'en ce moment il ya plus en plus de
personnes dans les commentaires qui se
battent véritablement pour défendre
telle ou telle youtuber et en a quatre
en attaque et d'autre chacun ses goûts
vous prenez pas la tête et comme je dis
souvent pis voilà
mais là c'est pas la fin de la vidéo fin
ça allait bientôt mais bon ta gueule
voilà cette fois c'est vraiment la fin
de cette vidéo on se retrouvait dans une
nouvelle vidéo j'ai tellement parlé que
je n'ai plus de salive c'est très grave
tchato monde pis